members of the u.s women's national
soccer team are among the first athletes
to take part in a protest
at the tokyo olympics they joined
several other teams yesterday taking a
knee on the field at the start of their
opening games to oppose
racism newly relaxed olympic rules allow
the athletes to express themselves
before the start of competition
it's part of a long history of
protesting at these games
jonathan bigliotti spoke to a man who
changed history
with his olympic protest back in the day
the year was 1968 american sprinter john
carlos joined by tommy smith
stood on the olympic medal podium in
mexico city their fists
raised high into the air as the national
anthem belted through the stadium
why am i being defined because i felt
like as a young individual
i represented america but at the same
time
america seems like it doesn't want me to
represent self
and that's a distaste in my in my mouth
and my mind
it was a silent call for civil rights
heard around the world
and one only made possible because of
the stage
on which he stood you know i could have
gone in front of the apollo theater i
was raised in harlem
i could have gone there i could have
been in europe and made a statement
but the statement would not reach the
masses that i'm trying to reach
i'm not the only person as a black man
in peril here in the united states
there are people of color that's in
peril in peril around the world
we need to send a message out to give
them hope as well
that we're fighting for a better day for
all people the medal had no significance
to me
that was my ticket to reach the victory
stand and that was my essence and
purpose of going to the olympic games
was to make a statement not to win a
medal or show the world how great i was
in track and field
so for you taking that platform and
using it
to send your message was more important
than even placing to begin with
absolutely it was just as important
today as it was back at that time
i'm committed to this i'm not in here
for the moment i'm here for the movement
that movement has exploded since that
momentous day
53 years ago from colin kaepernick's
neil
to nba and wnba players locking arms
to hammer thrower gwen berry looking
away from the american flag
at these olympic trials gwen barry is
a symbol of defiance you know
heart symbol is like john lewis said
she created good trouble understand and
that's something that you should be
proud of
when particularly when a people or race
of people
are in the fire many individuals run
when that in that crisis situation but
there are certain individuals that stand
tall
for all those individuals that stood as
well as those that ran
this year the international olympic
committee announced new rules for the
games that will still deter these acts
they allow athletes to protest before
their events
but not during competition or on the
podium
punishments will vary case by case it's
a really difficult balancing act
doug hartman is a sociology professor
and expert on athlete activism
at the university of minnesota he
expects protests at these games across
the spectrum of human rights causes
i think it's a really catch-22 tough
spot
that the olympic movement has put itself
in by
making grand claims about its
progressive role
in the world but also thinking that that
happens kind of naturally and
organically when in fact i think an
awful lot of
sports progressive forces come
through conflict through people speaking
out
and protesting that's the message of
john carlos
that speaking out can help bring unity
and respect
to all no matter the pedestal from which
it comes
i didn't pull my pants down show my butt
i didn't give the finger
i didn't do anything it was distasteful
i think what i did was very
uh educational it was very
thought-provoking
if you could give a word to the fist up
in the air
what would it be well in essence the
fish is this if you look at that hand
it's open hand but when you sit back and
think about how
frail this is as five individuals but
think about when these five individuals
come together how powerful they'd be
that was the essence of the fish it
wasn't about black power it's about
unity amongst people that have the right
mindset for cbs this morning jonathan
vigliotti
los angeles wow so powerful john carlos
it's it's a shame that
we're still having this conversation all
these years later but i thought it was
an interesting point that he made
i was just trying to get a message
across that i'd never i've never heard
it i've never heard that before either i
mean
it's it's hard to understate how
shocking that protest was
right in 1968 and because people didn't
do that sort of thing in sport what
we've learned now in the current age is
is how many athletes are are willing to
do that and how important it is
to force change yeah fighting for a
better day for all people that's what he
said to jonathan bigliotti and he's
still doing that today it's an
uncomfortable conversation for a lot of
people but it's a conversation
that we really do have to have yeah well
done john good to hear from you yeah
excellent